eskalation im syrienkonflikt die türkei
öffnet die grenzen zur eu und tausende
migranten flüchten nach griechenland
historisches abkommen für afghanistan
18 jahre nach kriegsbeginn einigen sich
die usa und die taliban auf einen weg
zum frieden virus auf dem vormarsch die
zahl der korona infizierten in
deutschland steigt weiter
darunter jetzt auch vier kinder aus
nordrhein westfalen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute an einem nachrichten starken
samstag und auch der sport hat einiges
zu bieten kristin otto ein turbulenter
tag bei uns guten abend heute ist das
corona virus etwas nach hinten gerückt
denn große sorgen macht die eskalation
des syrien kriegs seit den tödlichen
angriffen auf seine soldaten dort vor
zwei tagen hat der türkische präsident
nun zu vergeltungsschlägen ausgeholt
dazu kommt dass erdogan die grenze zu
griechenland geöffnet hat und tausende
flüchtlinge in die eu gehen lässt
dominik lässt meister es sind tausende
die versuchen über die landgrenze nach
griechenland zu kommen
die griechische polizei setzt tränengas
ein immer mehr flüchtlinge machen sich
auf den weg dahin
an einigen stellen schaffen sie es nach
griechenland zu gelangen
ich gehe nach europa weil ich meine
ausbildung fortsetzen möchte
in syrien musste ich sie abbrechen das
leben in der türkei ist nicht großartig
die türkei grenzt auf dem landweg an
griechenland und bulgarien die stadt
ideale ist gerade mal zweieinhalb
autostunden von istanbul entfernt
ungeachtet der vereinbarung mit der eu
lässt die türkei flüchtlinge in diese
richtung ziehen
wir werden die grenze nicht schließen
und das wird weitergehen
warum die eu muss ihr wort halten und
ihre versprechen erfüllen
erdogan betont die türkei habe bereits
mehr als 3,6 millionen flüchtlinge aus
syrien aufgenommen weitere könne man
nicht versorgen
griechenland will die eu außengrenze
schützen spricht davon mehr als 4000
illegale über dritte verhindert zu haben
endlich yuma dynamisch was wir
verstärken unsere streitkräfte zu land
und zu wasser
weitere polizei und armee truppen sind
auf den weg in das gebiet um den
grenzfluss evros auf den inseln erhöhen
wir die truppen der küstenwache
unterdessen startete die türkei weitere
angriffe in der syrischen provinz idlib
zerstörte nach eigenen angaben eine
anlage zum bau von chemiewaffen
der konflikt in nordsyrien eskaliert wir
schauen jetzt in das konfliktgebiet in
den ort rehan lee direkt an der grenze
zwischen der türkei und syrien
in dieser region koordiniert die türkei
ihre militäraktion
und da steht auch unser korrespondent
jörg brase den ich fragen möchte was
erdogan mit seinen aktionen in syrien
eigentlich bezweckt
nun man muss sehen dass alleine im
februar in syrien 53 türkische soldaten
getötet wurden das heißt die türkische
führung muss darauf reagieren
alleine schon um dem eigenen volk zu
zeigen dass der tod ihrer soldaten nicht
umsonst gewesen ist aber das ist
natürlich sehr riskanten wenn die
vergeltungsschläge summers sie
fortgeführt werden dann ist es
eigentlich nur eine frage der zeit bis
auch russische soldaten getötet werden
und damit der konflikt militärisch
weiter eskalieren könnte auch der druck
den die türkei versucht durch die
syrischen flüchtlinge auf europa
auszuüben
könnt ihr hier nicht ohne folgen bleiben
nur wenige kilometer hinter mir auf
syrischer seite sind die ersten lager
für zehntausende syrische flüchtlinge
und unter denen hat sich natürlich auch
herumgesprochen dass die türkei die
grenze im westen richtung griechenland
geöffnet hat dort wächst also die unruhe
und könnte den druck auf die türkische
grenze von syrischer seite noch weiter
erhöhen
vielen dank für ihre erklärung wird
brase war das in reha in katars
hauptstadt doha heute eine historische
unterschrift und die große frage was
kann sie wirklich verändern
die usa und die radikal islamischen
taliban haben ein abkommen unterzeichnet
es soll frieden bringen für afghanistan
das aber ist schwer vorstellbar nach
mehr als 18 jahren krieg und terror etwa
100.000 zivilisten wurden getötet oder
verletzt fast 2000 us soldaten kamen bei
an
pflegen und angriffen ums leben über den
deal zwischen washington und den
islamisten berichtet elmar theveßen
us-außenminister mike kompon wollte
dabei sein aber unterschreiben sollten
lieber andere die verhandlungsführer der
usa und der taliban
letztere sollen verhindern dass andere
terrorgruppen amerika je wieder
angreifen können die taliban versprechen
auch eine reduzierung der gewalt um die
entwicklung des landes zu ermöglichen
die us truppenpräsenz würde von über
12.000 soldaten zunächst auf 8600
reduziert fernziel ist ein weitgehender
rückzug amerikas
das afghanische volk dürfte nach der
chance die wir ihm nun bieten jeder
afghanische anführer sollte in sich
gehen und dann diesen frieden liefern
wenn die taliban ihre zusagen nicht
einhalten dann wird präsident trump ohne
zögern das tun was er muss um amerikaner
zu beschützen
ein historischer handschlag aber kann
man terroristen trauen die terror
organisation verlangt eine beteiligung
an der macht im nächsten schritt soll es
verhandlungen zwischen den taliban und
der afghanischen regierung geben die
nicht teil des friedens steals war die
hoffnung auf einen dauerhaften frieden
mit sich angst dass das terror regime
der taliban in teilen zur rückkehr
meine sorge ist dass die taliban die in
der gesellschaft jetzt vorbereitete
akzeptanz von frauen nicht dulden werde
sarah habib träumt von einer karriere
als musikerin jetzt fürchtet die
13-jährige um ihren traum wenn eine
gruppe wie die taliban wieder ins land
zurückkehrt hätte ich keine freiheit für
meine ausbildung das besorgt mich aber
ich habe auch viel hoffnung für die
zukunft hoffnung wie so viele aber wenn
die menschen enttäuscht werden könnten
sie sich im stich gelassen fühlen von
den usa in deutschland ist die zahl der
nachgewiesenen corona infektionen bis
zur stunde auf mehr als 70 angestiegen
die meisten davon entfallen auf
nordrhein westfalen vor allem den kreis
heinsberg dort melden die behörden heute
dass der erreger auch bei vier kindern
nachgewiesen wurde
volker dutschek berichtet das schild ist
unmissverständlich alle kindergärten und
schulen im kreis heinsberg bleibt bis
montag einschließlich geschlossen schuld
ist auch die korona krankmeldung einer
erzieherin in diesem kindergarten in
gangelt
die kinder wurden schließlich auf das
virus untersucht das sind rund 100 oder
über 100 kinder getestet worden vier
waren infiziert aber die haben
allenfalls leichter schnupfen symptome
der krisenstab der bundesregierung
empfiehlt aktuell anstehende
großveranstaltungen zu streichen zum
beispiel die idee die größte reisemesse
der welt in berlin abgesagt die
weltgrößte messe für fitness wellness
und gesundheit in köln verschoben
gemeinsame sache machen seit heute
borussia dortmund und bayern münchen und
verbieten ihren starke kann das
autogramm schreiben und self eis mit den
fans seit gestern gelten weitere
vorschriften für den luft und
schiffsverkehr wer aus china japan
südkorea iran und italien einreist muss
seinen gesundheitszustand vor der
einreise melden die bahn muss künftig
aussteiger karten ausfüllen wenn etwa
ein passagier krankheitssymptome zeigt
erkrankungen müssen den behörden
gemeldet werden
händler verzeichnen inzwischen eine
höhere nachfrage nach haltbaren
lebensmitteln engpässe drohen nach
einschätzung des handels aber nicht auch
andere länder registrieren immer mehr
corona fälle italien meldet mehr als
1000 infektionen und neben china mit
mehr als 79.000 fällen ist besonders
südkorea betroffen
dort gibt es mittlerweile 3000
infizierte innerhalb eines tages
steckten sich mehr als 800 menschen neu
mit dem erreger an über alle aktuellen
entwicklungen rund um die epidemie
halten wir sie online jederzeit auf dem
laufenden
mit antworten auf die häufigsten fragen
und in einem live blog auf heute de und
in der app wir schauen in die slowakei
wo die empörung über ein politisches
verbrechen die heutige parlamentswahl
entscheiden könnte es geht um den mord
am journalisten jan kozak und seiner
verlobten vor zwei jahren
der drahtzieher soll aus dem dunstkreis
der regierenden sozialdemokraten kommen
letzten umfragen zufolge dürften sie für
den mord abgestraft werden und könnten
die macht verlieren
britta hilpert es wirkt nur unaufgeregt
aber für die slowaken sind diese wahlen
an das seit zwei jahren ist das land in
politischem aufruhr
die männer hoffen alle dass ich etwas
radikal ändert es geht um die korruption
und die mafiösen praktiken sind die
nicht zu einer demokratie passt absolut
report
vor zwei jahren wurden der journalist
jan kozak und seine verlobte erschossen
aufgefunden
der mord löste landesweit proteste aus
denn das motiv waren seine recherchen zu
verbindungen zwischen mafia und
sozialdemokratische regierung premier
fico musste zurücktreten blieb aber chef
der sozialdemokratischen
regierungspartei und die stürzt nun ab
in umfragen bei dieser ersten
parlamentswahl seit dem journalisten
mord andere bekommen aufwind auch
rechtsradikale aber am meisten gestärkt
wird die demokratische alternative
es gibt nun eine mehrheit für jene
politischen parteien die versprechen
korruption zu bekämpfen und die
proeuropäische keine partei schafft wohl
die absolute mehrheit er aber hofft auf
die führung in einer neuen
koalitionsregierung igor markevitch
führt in umfragen weil er ganz auf ein
thema setzt abb mafia ich werde alles
tun damit die mafia nicht wieder an die
macht kommt die wahlbeteiligung ist wohl
höher als zuletzt denn viele meinen
heute ist es eine richtungswahl bus bahn
und straßenbahn für alle gratis
als erstes land der welt hat luxemburg
heute den kostenlosen öffentlichen
nahverkehr eingeführt ausgenommen sind
nur die erste klasse in der bahn und
einige nachtbusse
so soll der autoverkehr drastisch
verringert werden
die umstellung kostet den staaten mehr
als 40 millionen euro pro jahr
und nun nach berlin und zu ganz großem
kino bei der berlinale dem größten
publikums filmfestival der welt dreht
sich zur stunde alles um ihn den
goldenen bären
denn nach zehn tagen mit zelluloid und
stars verkündet die jury
wer den hauptpreis bekommt 18 filme sind
dafür und für die weiteren
auszeichnungen ins rennen gegangen nadia
nasa sagte uns wer zu den favoriten
zählt und wie die berlinale so ankam
endspurt auf dem roten teppich die jury
unter dem vorsitz von jeremy irons hat
entschieden jetzt sind alle gespannt wer
die bären gewinnt der neue künstlerische
leiter zieht bilanz
es war ein großartiger ritt natürlich
sehen wir von unserer seite aus nur
einen teil der realität aber ich glaube
dass wir es geschafft haben menschen
über filme miteinander zu verbinden
gleich zwei deutsche wettbewerbsfilme
haben gute chancen auf einen bären beide
zds koproduktionen und diene von
regisseur christian petzold und berlin
alexanderplatz eine moderne verfilmung
des klassikers von alfred döblin
fantastisch albrecht schuch als fieser
drogenhändler reinhold preis für dich
die arbeit ist nicht ungefährlich aber
sie lohnt sich hochgelobt auch der us
amerikanische beitrag never really
sometimes always über eine 17-jährige
die ungewollt schwanger wird und nach
new york reist um abzutreiben ein
berührender film mit einer großartigen
hauptdarstellerin der wohl größte
favorit auf den goldenen bären aber
kommt aus dem iran auch dieser film eine
zdf-koproduktion es gibt kein böses
erzählt von menschen die sich
entscheiden müssen ob sie mit dem regime
kooperieren oder sich widersetzen
regisseur mohammad rasoulof durfte nicht
aus dem iran ausreisen wird auf der gala
fehlen
vor wenigen minuten hat die
preisverleihung begonnen
[Musik]
der ein oder andere wird es nicht mal
bemerkt haben aber den tag heute gibt es
nur alle vier jahre
es ist schaltjahr der februar hat einen
tag mehr aber warum eigentlich
die erde braucht etwas länger als ein
jahr um die sonne zu umkreisen sind 365
tage und fünf stunden 48 minuten und 46
sekunden ohne anpassung würden sich
monate sonnenstand und jahreszeiten
immer mehr verschieben
so wäre der frühlingsanfang irgendwann
im dezember
deshalb hat bereits julius cäsar den
schalttag in jedem vierten jahr
eingeführt große tat und jetzt sind wir
beim sport ist immer viel los das
gutachten ernst einen tag nach dem
dreifachtriumph der deutschen herren
nutzt auch tina herrmann den heimvorteil
und rast bichtlingen es bei den skeleton
weltmeisterschaften im eiskanal von
altenberg zum titelgewinn
welch ein jubel
ich kann es gar nicht richtig glauben
ich freue mich aber riesig und der
starke glaubt wahnsinn
tina herrmann kann erst im letzten lauf
ihr können komplett abrufen geht mit
bahnrekord in führung aber als letzte
die schweizerin marina gilardoni auf der
strecke deren vorsprung beträgt 66
hundertstelsekunden doch die nerven
halten nicht im ziel liegt sie 22
hundertstel hinter tina herrmann die
diesen überraschungserfolg entsprechend
feiert deutsche erfolge auch im rodeln
zum saisonende am königssee gewinnt nach
den doppelsitzern toni eggert/sascha
benecken auch julia taubitz den
gesamtweltcup die wm-zweite setzt damit
die serie von 22 gesamtsiegen für
deutsche rodlerinnen ford dafür reichte
heute platz zwei hinter teamkollegin
anna bereit
deutschlands besten alpinen skifahrer
thomas dreesen droht eine zwangspause
der 26 jährige stürzt beim super g in
hinterstoder und kugelt sich beide
schultern aus entsetzen und
fassungslosigkeit in der fußball
bundesliga die am 24 spieltag ein
tiefpunkt erlebt die partie hoffenheim
gegen bayern münchen musste wegen übler
beleidigungen von der tribüne durch
einige chaoten gegen dietmar hopp
zweimal unterbrochen werden
mehr dazu und dem solidarischen
reaktionen beider mannschaften im
aktuellen sportstudio das ergebnis null
zu sechs zweitrangig außerdem dortmund
freiburg 1 0 augsburg mönchengladbach 23
mainz paderborn 2 0 das abendspiel köln
schalke ausführlich im sportstudio
gestern düsseldorf härter 33 morgen
union berlin wolfsburg und leipzig
leverkusen bremen frankfurt wurde
abgesagt
in der tabelle festigen die bayern ihre
spitzenposition
dortmund bleibt dritter vor gladbach mit
einem spiel weniger dahinter kann sich
noch einiges verschieben
in der unteren hälfte rutscht die härter
vorerst vor köln am tabellenende
verschafft sich mainz etwas luft im
abstiegskampf
schlusslicht paderborn nun mit fünf
punkten rückstand auf den
relegationsplatz und die hässlichen
szenen auf dem fußball tribünen 1 der
brisanten themen die katrin
müller-hohenstein von 23 uhr an mit dfb
präsident fritz keller besprechen wird
anderes thema grandios überragend so
überschwänglich wurde die goldmedaille
im sprint von emma hintze bei der
bahnrad wm in berlin bejubelt und es gab
noch mehr zu feiern für die gastgeber
ebenfalls gold gab es für lea sophie
friedrich im 500 meter zeitfahren
die 20 jährige startete eher verhalten
und lag bis kurz vor schluss noch zurück
kämpfte sich aber nach starker
aufholjagd bis ganz nach vorne der
sophie friedrich ist damit die jüngste
weltmeisterinnen der geschichte dieser
disziplin und holte bereits ihre zweite
goldmedaille
nach dem erfolg im teamsprint am
mittwoch und so eben gab es noch zwei
weitere medaillen einmal silber in der
einerverfolgung der frauen für lisa
brennauer und bronze für franziska
brause toll
danke zum wetter das durch regen und
wind immer ungemütlicher wird wo sich am
sonntag aber die sonne
zeigt fahren sie gleich von besten terry
das war es von uns das heute journal mit
claus kleber um viertel vor elf
wir danken für ihr interesse und sind
morgen wieder für sie da um 19 uhr
schönen abend noch
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir schauen kurz
zurück auf den winter und der war zu
warm es war der zweitwärmste
deutschlandweit und im osten
deutschlands sogar in berlin und
brandenburg der wärmste seit 1881
schauen wir auf das aktuelle wetter und
da haben wir es mit einer kaltfront zu
tun die zieht langsam nach osten ja und
über nacht wird das sein und dann kommt
morgen ein neues tief aus dem westen und
bringt neuen regen und viel wind
schauen wir in die nacht regen und
schnee bis auf 500 meter etwa fällt dann
in der nacht das zieht dann allmählich
weiter ostwärts die temperaturen sinken
dabei auf 1 grad an den alpen und 7 grad
im südwesten deutschlands das ist die
spanne der temperaturen morgen im
tagesverlauf verschwindet der regen im
süden neuer kommt im westen auf
dazwischen aber auch sonnige abschnitte
und viel wind vor allem richtung nordsee
stürmische böen
und das bei temperaturen von sechs bis
sieben grad zum beispiel an den alpen
und 15 grad im südwesten deutschlands
die nächsten tage gibt es immer wieder
mal schauer teils regen teils schnee in
den bergen temperaturen liegen bei 5 bis
und das ändert sich in den nächsten
tagen kaum ein schöner abend